welcome to the team i'm going to stream
i watched the first four episodes of
this series and i gotta tell you the
series felt
funny lighthearted warm
you're no stranger of course to animated
shows
what to you i guess felt different or
exciting about this the comedy
uh of the great north is is so unique
uh the the voice is just so very special
and i think
as a comedian you're you're always
looking for something that's surprising
and that isn't reiterative that that
really sort of
takes a new space and um and so i think
our show really does that and and as you
said it's also it's really warm
um for a show that takes place in alaska
um
and i know i am i am looking for that in
the entertainment that i watch these
days
is like i just want something that is
going to make me feel
um good in a way that feels real the
show
is getting uh uh some comparisons to
bob's burgers
which you were also a part of because of
the success
of that series do you feel an added
pressure
on this show i think that you know i
i hold bob's burgers in very high regard
um i think a lot of people do
yeah it's one of the funniest animated
shows ever ever
ever so i guess you know it does kind of
make me
want to bring my a game of course
um and it also makes me feel really
really grateful to be chosen to be in
this project
um because they've already worked with
me before the first few episodes
are available to stream now but it's
officially out i guess
on february 14th what is your message to
people
going into the show for the first time
oh
let us be your valentine
[Laughter]
that's cute that's precious there's so
much to love on our show and there's so
many
funny examples of like very specific
um connections with romance whether it's
wolf and honeybee
who are an engaged couple played by will
forte and dulce sloane
they're movie buffs and their love is
like very specific
a little bit dorky and like completely
committed
or my character judy who's a 16 year old
girl who
is in love with crispin who's the
slightly older boy who works at smoothie
boss
in the mall i am a true romantic so it's
it's first of all like very very nice to
have our
our show coming out on valentine's day
um it's a it's sort of a
just like makes me feel cozy you guys
also of course have nick offerman
megan malali and my personal favorite
alanis morissette
what was it like to have her be part of
this
um to get to even be
in like the same state as alanis morris
said is a real dream come true
uh she's someone who i have like
specifically loved
you know since she saved my spirit in my
teen years
and so i think like working with her is
a true gift and it's also a
a constant um you know effort to try to
not geek out
and be weird around her and i don't
really think that i
have achieved that but did you geek out
around her
oh yeah i mean i like definitely was
like can we take a selfie you know
like ask for the selfie and
i would have done the same thing and i
sat next to her
at our first table read and like
could just feel the like the clamminess
and like just like
so do i look over and say like hey
like did you try it like no like what
just trying to be normal um is hard but
i think you know it was okay but don't
ask
her don't ask her don't be suspicious
don't be suspicious
changing gears a little bit more did you
ever think that your
don't be suspicious parks and rec scene
would become the tick-tock trend
phenomenon
that it has become like it is not a joke
when i say i'm
not internety like i or even computery
like i don't i don't know how to take a
screenshot on my computer and i don't
get what tick-tock is
um and i haven't seen it but one of my
friends was like do you know that this
thing is happening
yes and i said no i don't and then
i kind of tried to figure out how to
but i just can't so but it's funny
cool right it seems like a good thing
and oh my gosh and i love being on parks
and rec and i love playing mona lisa so
if people are still enjoying her that
makes me really happy do you ever see a
world where mona lisa
and john ralphio have a spin-off series
i think ben said it would never happen
but yeah i don't think you won as much
as you think you want you know like i
don't wanna know
just that uh i think those characters
are wonderful in small doses although i
will say
i could play mona lisa all day
um because it's incredibly fun
you